بعدما بدا المرشح الجمهوريه الاوفر حظا
لتمثيل الحزب في انتخابات رئاسه 2024 يعني
حاكم فلوريدا السياسي الصاعد
اليوم ارقام استطلاعاته تتدهور امام
منافسي الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في مواجهه ترامب وقع ديسانس في فخ
اتخاذ مواقفها اكثر تحفظا واكثر ميلا
لاقصى اليمين
بعدما كان منذ اشهر بمثابه المرشح
الجمهوري المعتدل وهو الفخ ذاته الذي وقع
فيه تدكروز امام ترامب في انتخابات 2016
ارتكب ديسانس عده اخطاء بحسب نيويورك
تايمز ابرزها اعلان موقف لين نسبيا اتجاه
روسيا فيما يخص الحرب الاوكرانيه كما ان
معركه حاكم فلوريدا مع شركه ديزني لم
تساعده معركه بدات بتقديم ديزني انتقادات
معتدله لقانون فلوريدا لحقوق الوالدين في
التعليم لتصل الى دعوه قضائيه من الشركه
تتهم فيها ديسانتس بالانتقام منها بسبب
تعبيرها السياسي المحمي دستوريا تفادى
معظم المرشحين الجمهوريين انتقاد ترامب في
اطار القضايا المرفوعه ضده خوفا من التعرض
لسيل غضبه وحرصا على مراعاه الناخبين
الذين يكونون له اعجابا هائلا وحده روند
سنتيس انتقده ما جعله يواجه حمله غضب من
ترامب ومعسكره مثلت موجه التاييد الترامب
سلسله مخيبه للامال من الانشقاقات بالنسبه
لكن ديسانس يعول في مواجهته مع ترامب على
صندوق انتخابي قدره 110 ملايين دولار يامل
ان يمكنه من التعويض قليلا عن تاخره من
خلال شن حمله اعلانات على مستوى البلاد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات